no
[Música]
seguramente nunca he escuchado hablar de
yo sé de amy de rosemary
o de joaquín el común denominador de
todos ellos es que son niños con muy
bajos recursos pero con muchísimo
talento talento que corría el riesgo de
perder de perderse porque todos ellos
estudiaban en un colegio público hace
unos años seguramente ustedes recuerdan
que salió el ranking pisa el ranking
pisa es un ranking que mide la calidad
de educación en los países que
participan en ese ranking perú quedó
último
65 de 65 países la buena noticia de eso
es que en la próxima oración en el peor
de los casos no podemos estar peor
pero eso es preocupante de repente
algunos saben que según el ministerio de
educación el 59 por ciento de escuelas
públicas aproximadamente 57 39 por
ciento de escuelas públicas no cuentan
con los tres servicios básicos de luz
agua potable o que según esta misma
fuente según la evaluación censal
educativa del año pasado del 2015
solamente el 15 por ciento fíjense bien
el 15 por ciento de estudiantes de
segundo de secundaria u octavo grado
comprenden lo que leen en el caso de
matemáticas es aún peor es solamente 10%
entienden matemáticas a nivel que
deberían de estar esa es la realidad de
la educación pública la pregunta es que
estamos haciendo para mejorar esa
situación
le voy a contar los momentos
que marcaron mi vida dos momentos de mi
vida personal el primero tiene que ver
con mi familia la verdad es que uno no
escoge donde nacer no uno escoge en qué
familia nacer algunos pueden hacer una
familia con mucho dinero con poco dinero
en la costa en la tierra en la selva
mamá soltera
el hermano menor hermano mayor lo que
sea podría uno no escoge uno nació nada
más en una familia que le tocó yo tuve
la suerte de nacer en una familia que me
que a mí a mi hermana nos dieron
muchísimo amor sobre todas las cosas y
lo segundo fue que nos inculcaron el
valor de una buena educación yo recuerdo
que cuando estaba en el último grado de
colegio mi papá me preguntó
qué quieres estudiar y en donde mi
respuesta fue quier estudiar economía en
una las mejores universidades del país
que por cierto es la más cara
en ese momento recuerdo haber visto a mi
papá que funcionó un poco el diseño no
preocupaba
les doy un poco de contexto mi papá es
empresario como muchos ustedes saben a
un empresario se le va bien le salga mal
en esa época eran épocas difíciles en el
país en el papá no le estaba yendo tan
bien
y ante eso yo dije papá no te preocupes
porque puedo buscar otras alternativas
más baratas o buscar becas qué sé yo y
lo que me dijo me marcó porque no me lo
que me dijo fue no te preocupes tú vas a
estudiar lo que quieres lo que quieras
donde quieras yo me encargo de que eso
suceda
y efectivamente estudiar economía en esa
universidad muy cara y me fue bastante
bien pero fui testigo de todo el
sacrificio que mis padres hicieron para
que tanto yo como mi hermana cuando mi
hermana como yo
pudiésemos estudiar lo que queríamos
donde queríamos y eso marcó mi vida la
segunda situación
fue tiene que ver con mi trabajo
hace mucho tiempo una persona que yo
conocía profesionalmente creyó en mí y
decidió invertir en mi talento
hace esa fecha de repente además de mis
padres o algún que otro incauto yo no
sabía que tenía talento talento yo sí
bueno en el colegio donde estuve está en
los primeros puestos y bastante aplicado
práctica algunos deportes era bueno en
unos pocos muy malo en la mayoría pero
aún así lo practicaba en el trabajo
también me fue bien ascendieron rápido
manejar una cartera importante de
clientes pero talento yo la verdad es
que hasta la fecha yo no sé si tengo
talento o no pero lo que sí sé es que
esa persona vio algo en mí que otros no
había notado la decisión que hizo que
tomó esa persona de ayudar me marcó mi
vida para siempre me hizo ser una mejor
persona y todas las decisiones que
tomaba a partir de ese momento han
tenido que ver con lo que pasó
la real academia de la lengua española
define talento como inteligencia aptitud
la capacidad para hacer algo y
oportunidad como el momento o
circunstancia conveniente para 'la se
acuerdan los cuatro nombres que les dije
al comienzo de la charla esos cuatro
niños son niños super super súper
talentosos que tienen ganas de hacer que
tienen ganas de aprender que tienen
ganas de cambiar este país el problema
es que no tenían la oportunidad para
hacerlo esa es la realidad en la que
vivimos la pregunta es qué podemos hacer
para darles esa oportunidad
y que puedan lucir el talento que tienen
para cambiar y mejorar la vida de otros
para responder esa pregunta es que nace
de luchar lo que hacemos en perú champs
es darle oportunidad a niños de bajos
recursos pero con mucho talento a que
reciban una educación de calidad
internacional como lo hacemos conectamos
a estos niños con donantes del periodo
el mundo que quieran para realizar la
educación esos niños
nuestra misión es potenciar el talento
de los futuros líderes de bajos recursos
a través de una buena educación y una
formación en liderazgo
cuando comenzamos hace algunos años hace
tres años comenzamos con 232 becarios a
los que vamos a llamar champs de ahora
en adelante a la fecha este año tenemos
más de 2.000 niños en 11 ciudades del
país
las tres características que buscamos en
nuestro champs son la primera es que
tenga necesidad económica obviamente
porque si tienes los fondos para pagar
una buena educación bueno que la pague y
que esa beca vaya a alguien que de
verdad la necesita la segunda es que
tenga potencial de liderazgo porque lo
que queremos hacer es formar a los
futuros líderes este país que va a
impactar este país y cambiarlo para
mejor y la tercera característica
probablemente la más importante es que
tengan talento ahora cuando hablamos de
talento no nos referimos solamente al
talento académico en este país el bien
común o es más común digamos no bien
común es más común hablar de temas de
talento académico no si eres una
matemáticas lenguaje que se lleva de
repente te dan una beca podés conseguir
por ahí nosotros no distinguimos entre
tipo de talento puede ser tanto
académico puede ser talento deportivo
artístico astronómico cualquier tipo de
talento ahora al momento de revaluación
el talento académico es fácil de
evaluarlo pero el talento deportivo
artístico lo que hacemos es nos
asociamos con realizaciones
que si bien ese talento y que evalúen y
que que saben pueden identificar a niños
que son talentosos y ellos son quienes
nos refieren a esos niños y ellos
postulan ahora
el programa tiene dos componentes
importantes el primero es la beca de
estudios de un componente financiero que
es la beca de estudios para que se den
una idea estudiar en el colegio aliado
con el cual trabajamos cuesta más o
menos en promedio 120 dólares mensuales
nosotros tenemos que siempre siempre el
padre de familia pague el 25 por ciento
de ese importe
o sea 30 dólares porque porque queremos
que se involucre que se sacrifique que
nos demuestre con ese pequeño pago de
que efectivamente le interesa la
educación de sus hijos y eso hace una
diferencia importante en resultados
finales además de eso bueno el otro 75%
perdón nosotros lo conseguimos de
donantes del pri del mundo que quieran
pagar la educación de estos niños además
de eso nosotros le damos el cien por
ciento de los libros
ese es el componente financiero que es
importante que es un poco lo que jala
que mucha gente aplique al programa
pero para mí el segundo componente es el
componente más importante que es el
componente de liderazgo
en el componente de liderazgo lo que
hacemos es potenciar el talento de los
niños el talento que ya tienen
complementándolo con el desarrollo de
habilidades blandas y el desarrollo de
valores porque estos niños ya son
talentosos entonces lo que hacemos es a
través de este programa reforzar
conceptos como por ejemplo
trabajo en equipo
e inteligencia emocional emprendimiento
autoestima habilidades sociales sentido
posibilidad integridad solidaridad
comunicación liderazgo en general
reforzamos todos estos conceptos y
valores porque sabemos que ellos son
claves para que estas personas tengan la
mayor probabilidad de éxito en el futuro
y así puedan ayudar no solamente a ellos
mismos sino a sus familias a la
comunidad y sobre todo al país creo que
finalmente queremos
se acuerdan que
le mencioné cuatro nombres al comienzo
esos cuatro nombres de los chicos que
mencioné son champs son becados del
programa el primero yo sé es un niño que
a los siete años piensen piensen bien
qué estás haciendo los siete años a los
siete años
fundó el primer banco ecológico para
estudiantes del mundo
yo soy seguro que mucho de ustedes se
han preguntando qué diablos es eso no
les explico lo que hizo fue se dio
cuenta que muchos de sus compañeros en
el colegio se quejaban de que no tenían
los fondos para sacar copia a las para
sacar las copias que la maestra le pedía
entonces qué hizo
hay que reforzar el concepto de ahorro
habló con habló con ellos se les pidió
que les trajeran cuadernos usados
o botellas de plástico y fue con su papá
a venderlas a empresas que utilizan esos
materiales con los fondos regresó lo
distribuyó entre sus compañeros en
función de los materiales que le habían
dado y los depósitos monederos
electrónicos con la única condición de
cruzarán esos fondos para actividades
relacionadas con el colegio yo sé ha
participado en un montón de competencias
internacionales hace poco participó en
una organizada por el gobierno británico
kev entre los finalistas
la reina isabel segunda inglaterra lo
invitó a yo sé a tomar té con ella
porque había salido los finalistas la
mayor preocupación de josep para que
vean la sencillez de ese niño era
desarmar el nombre del perú porque a él
no le gustaba el té o diente
no era estar de frente la reina no hacer
la venia todo el tema que hacen estos
casi no era simplemente era ese tema
pero es ellos
las otras dos nombres adicionales y
menciones son los de rosemary y amy las
dos son dos niñas que crecieron en una
provincia al sur del país una provincia
con mucha pobreza
su papá tuvo que cambiar las nueve veces
del colegio porque los papás entendían
el valor de una buena educación y sabían
que educación que estaban recibiendo los
colegios donde estaban las niñas estas
dos niñas eran muy malas
les cuento ellas dos son campeones son
campeonas de matemáticas debate ajedrez
son muy inteligentes pero papá no estaba
contento por suerte conocido el programa
y los padres tuvieron la sensatez de
mandar a la mamá con las dos niñas a
vivir acá lina estudian en el colegio
que es nuestro aliado y lo que le sirvió
el programa que tenemos es básicamente
para validar lo que querían hacer se
dieron cuenta que en la vida no es sólo
hacer plata solo trabajar para hacer
plata y ser millonario y quien hace más
plata eso define el éxito lo que se
dieron cuenta por todo este programa y
liderazgo que hacemos con temas de
solidaridad y todo eso es que tienen que
ayudar a los que más tienen
romer y cerrado el año pasado estudió
economía es una muy buena universidad y
actualmente dentro de su meta es está
tratando cuando se gradúe quiere tratar
de solucionar los problemas de escasez
que afectan a los más pobres y la menor
amy que además está adelantada dos años
en el colegio se gradúa en unas semanas
ahora en diciembre quiere ser doctora y
ha prometido que va a ayudar a las
personas que más lo necesiten en temas
de medicina lo va a curar gratis
básicamente
esas ellas esas dos chicas en mi remedio
también son parte de champs el caso más
trágico quizás
es el de joaquín joaquín es un niño rey
contra pero recontra pero recontra
inteligente joaquín estudiaba en un
colegio público en el cual pasaban tres
cosas la primera es que se aburría en el
colegio porque lo que le enseñaban no
era suficiente seguro ya le parecía muy
fácil le enseñaban algo lo aprendía al
toque y después ya no del resto de la
clase ya depreciado muy fácil y lo
segundo es que era primero de su plazo
porque porque es súper inteligente y
todo lo aprendía rápido lo tercero y más
grave es que a este pobre niño le hacían
bullying y hacían bullying no sólo
físico sino psicológico al punto que
joaquín en algún momento dijo el papá yo
no quiero ir más al colegio no sólo eso
su papá lo convenció obviamente que es
importante que fue sí que tenía que
seguir viendo pero este niño es tan
inteligente como mecanismos de defensa
dijo
yo no me voy a bañar voy a dejar de
bañarme los días lunes a la mañana y me
voy a volver a bañar los días viernes en
la tarde porque porque por lo menos y
huelo mal algunos de mis compañeros que
actualmente me pegan no se van a acercar
a pegar me insultaran pero no me pegaron
y así espero pasarla mejor esa era la
realidad de este niño por suerte conocí
el programa ingreso porque es un niño
muy inteligente y actualmente tiene la
ventaja
de que tiene amigos va al colegio feliz
aprende se baña todos los días de verdad
si ya ha cambiado la vida
talento yo hace 15 años una persona me
llamó a su oficina una persona conocida
por finalmente memos oficina y me dijo
alberto no te preocupes yo yo te voy a
pagar tu maestría en eeuu después de
agradecerle todo eso dije bueno como de
pago de vuelta lo que me dijo me marcó
porque aún lo que me dijo fue para mí
nada me dijo lo único que quieres tener
un momento hagas algo por alguien que lo
necesite qué haces cómo lo haces cuando
lo haces no importa me dijo con quién es
a cuántos intactas eso ve tú lo que sí
quiero que hagas es que sea en perú es
más me dijo yo nunca más te voy a
preguntar servicio no depende de ti tu
conciencia
esa decisión marcó mi vida
esa decisión hizo
todas mis decisiones futuras estuvieron
marcadas por ese gesto de esta persona
yo tengo el privilegio
actualmente devolverle a él y sobre todo
el perú la bondad que recibe a través
del programa que manejo
tengo la satisfacción de saber que mis
champs y niños se esfuerzan y aprender
en trabajar dura e íntegramente porque
saben que tienen una misión en la vida
que es ayudar a los que más lo necesitan
eso es lo que hace mi programa y esa es
la satisfacción que yo tengo yo les
aseguro y lo firmo ahorita
mis champs van a dejar un legado que va
a marcar un antes y un después en este
mundo lo afirmo y lo firmo orita la
pregunta que les quiero dejar antes de
terminar es que estamos haciendo
nosotros para devolver para devolverle a
nuestro país todo lo que hemos recibido
y sobre todo que estamos haciendo
nosotros para darle oportunidad estos
jóvenes que tienen talento para que este
talento no se desperdicie que dios los
bendiga y recuerden siempre que un
campeón lo puede todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]